michel larive député la france un
sourice de l'ariège bonsoir michel
larive merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors une nouvelle tête à
matignon un nouveau chemin annoncé par
l'elysée
le nouveau monde est en marche son goût
alors pour moi quand même le nouveau
monde
le monde d'après comme ils se disent
ressemble quand même furieusement nom
d'avant si vous avez un monsieur qui
comme emmanuel macron sur monsieur
hollande et l'ancien secrétaire général
de l'elysée mais sous monsieur sarkozy
voilà monsieur castex et passez vous
l'avez dit par le cabinet de monsieur
xavier bertrand il est d'ailleurs un peu
avant à l'origine d'ailleurs de la
tarification à l'acte c'est à dire qu'il
a fait rentrer la notion de rentabilité
dans l'hôpital moi j'ai pu le croiser à
l'assemblée nationale on nous l'avions
auditionné lorsque il me il était
président de l' agence nationale du
sport et donc son bilan va céder ce sont
des coupes budgétaires
le démantèlement du ministère des sports
la case des sports amateurs bien sûr la
fin du sport pour tous et le
développement du mécénat privé dans dans
le sport voilà donc pour nous ce que
nous voyons ici c'est qu'on remplace un
homme de droit par un autre homme de
droite mais on remplace un juppéiste par
un sarkozyste donc le virage social et
l'écologie d'un tant attendu et ce tout
en promis par emmanuel macron n'a
absolument pas vu vous l'avez croisé
quel genre de personnalité et il
on présente comme un gaulliste social
vous n'avez pas l'air de penser qu'il le
soit non non c'est un statut d'un
technocrate qui doit très très bien
faire son métier en l'occurrence aussi
gérer c'est un gestionnaire ce doit être
un un très bon gestionnaire mais
l'aspect social cantine j'entends lui
toner qu'il se disait gaulliste social
je veux bien gaulliste social non le
verdict le principal son paradigme
principal et l'a dit c'est l'économie
dont qu'il a il a économisé dans le
pour le pétale puisqu'elle a fait
l'intérêt la tarification à l'acte en
fait il a commencé il a entamé la
destruction de l'hôpital puis entamé la
destruction du ministère des sports et
la et le redis la france doit faire des
économies mais tu y vas faire ces
économies d'après vous je pense qu'elle
va se retourner toujours vers les mêmes
c'est à dire la plus grande partie de la
population celle qui commence maintenant
à se paupériser emmanuel macron à accra
c'est un chemin tout en maintenant le
cap c'est ce qu'il dit ce matin à la
presse quotidienne régionale
la réforme sur les
et sur les retraites va revenir sur le
devant de la scène vous pensez que jean
castex val a mené d'une main de fer
comme c'était le cas avec edouard
philippe
alors écoutez ce qu'il a dit toujours
que je le cite c'est la continuité de
l'action entreprise par monsieur edouard
philippe
donc on peut considérer qu'il sera au
moins aussi dur peut-être plus puisqu'on
est là dans un profil encore moins
social est bien plus adroites et dans le
cadre des orions si des orientations
fixées par le président de la république
qui lui vient de s'entourer d'un super
directeur de cabinet un super
collaborateurs mais n'est pas un premier
ministre c'est à dire que monsieur le
président de la république installe pour
les deux ans de mandat qui lui restent à
nouveau une hyper précis
présidentialisation et on appelle ça la
monarchie présidentielle il le dit
monsieur captain castex qui va aider le
président à relancer la réforme des
retraites je crois que c'est une très
mauvaise chose
la précarité a explosé nous avons un
nombre de chômeurs qui ne s'est jamais
vu depuis surnom la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
nous avons nous allons rentrer et le
président de l'addi dans une période de
conflits sociaux à la rentrée qui va
être une véritable poudrière
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'apaiser il ne faut surtout pas
relancer la réforme de retraites je
crois que à ma vie il faut aller sur
d'autres terrains s'il veut négocier la
première des choses pour négocier c'est
pas d'annoncer quelque chose qui va
absolument rebuter les partenaires
sociaux il ya aussi le ségur de la santé
qui est sur la table jean castex a une
expérience en la matière là il pourrait
faire avancer les choses selon vous ah
bah écoutez je vous en ai parlé de son
expérience son expérience et la
conception de la tarification à l'acte
dans l'hôpital c'est à dire la la mise
en place de la rentabilité à l'intérieur
de l'hôpital
et donc il risque de prendre ce concept
et de le décliner dans tous les services
publics c'est à dire que pour lui le
service public doit être rentable alors
que
c'est absolument le contraire un public
n'a pas à être rentable il a lieu d'être
à la série au service des populations
donc non je suis moins très très inquiet
de la tournure que va prendre la fin de
ce quinquennat de monsieur emmanuel
macron a besoin d'avoir les coudées
franches pour 2022 courroux c'est un
choix purement électoralistes d'aller
prendre un premier ministre de droite
qui est qu'elle est là quasi copie
conforme d'edouard philippe à ses débuts
c'est purement électoraliste pour garder
l'électorat et la réserve en tout cas
des voix à droite
ou pas oui oui parce que si vous voulez
dans l'arc où il est il a commencé dans
un quelque chose au centre qu'on pouvait
tout d'abord taxé de centre-gauche qui a
très vite viré au centre droit puis
ensuite à une politique véritablement de
droite d'ailleurs maintenant pour tous
les françaises et les français
la politique gouvernementale et
considéré comme une politique de droite
et emmanuel macron a complètement
détruit le parti socialiste a siphonné
complètement cette social-démocratie
néolibérale qui l'a amenée chez lui dans
la république en marche
il va maintenant il a déjà commencé s'il
faut mais à droite pour essayer d'avoir
le plus large spectre possible pour se
présenter en 2022 effectivement vous
l'avez dit c'est plutôt un sarkozyste
fillonniste même donc c'est plutôt une
droite dure qui l'incarnent jean castex
haut c'est à dire que là où il a oeuvré
il a oeuvré au sein des cercles de la
droite du lot maintenant nous allons
voir ce que va être surpris mais ça
m'étonnerait
je pense qu'effectivement c'est vrai une
politique de droite dure pas sociale et
il va y avoir derrière cette crise
sanitaire que nous avons vécu et là ça
va chez plusieurs fois pendant son
discours
il y aura cette crise économique et donc
lien effectivement d'ailleurs vous le
voyez
pour certaines grandes entreprises
françaises qui reçoit recomptant dz un
effet d'aubaine a apuré certaine masse
salariale killer quel est il est embêté
pour équipier équilibré certains comptes
et pour pouvoir dégager suffisamment de
davy dividendes pour contenter les
actionnaires et je pense que c'est vers
là qu'on va aller avec notre nouveau
premier ministre
merci michel larive d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rt france